[Music]
and here's a writer i love
I actually this is a man of war and I
borrowed my my best friend Amy beech
who's a beautiful nature writer she
wrote this line about men of war the men
of war appears to be one individual like
Leo Tolstoy but it's actually many
individuals living together as a colony
like Leo Tolstoy the Tolstoy she he
certainly had more big wise than anybody
else in the world so for years Tolstoy
ended his journal each day with three
letters initial for the Russian if I
live every month he began with the note
nearer to death so a few weeks ago I
actually went to Russia and I visited
yes nyah Pollyanna he stayed outside
Moscow and there I learned that he had
failed many things in life
he failed as schools in as a educator he
failed at breeding horses he failed at
farming and of course he also failed you
know eventually in his religious
endeavor pretty much the only thing he
didn't fail was to be a writer and as a
Babel in the Russian writer one of my
favorite writers said if the world could
if the world could write by itself they
would write like Tolstoy and I take that
to mean you know we know there are big
ways and small lies in life if you if
the world ruled itself like a tea
service Baldwin or Portia it would be
also big wise but with Tolstoy there the
balance of big ways and small lies the
big wise for many on a psychiatric ward
and to some to many people outside in
the world can be summarized as such why
live why suffer and why suffer on not
any one of us had an answer there and I
think particularly for those who have
experienced men
illness there's also another question we
cannot answer why are you you why are
you you and there are many variations of
the questions why are you not happy why
can't you stay hopeful why can't you see
the bright side of the world why are you
so selfish why can't you just be like
everyone else
why can't you be real why can't you be
rational the big whys are timeless
questions and in asking them I mean not
being able to find answers one puts
oneself in the timeless trap anyone
suffering at the severe depression may
have the experience the time coming to a
stop one day to the next
one minutes to the next time which is
the most precious possession we have
becomes the most treacherous thing it's
time real it's time rational is there a
way for us to experience time in the
real or rational manner time in the
world of physics is probably one of the
most democratic experience I would say
Trump's minute as as long as my minute a
dictator stays no one not one second
longer than my day but I'm experienced
by each individual as we all know is so
much less scientific so much less
reliable in life there are big white and
small lies easily we look around at our
lives and come up with abundant small
lies why do I agree to eat at this
restaurant but now they wanna cross the
street which was what I really wanted to
go why do I read the news first thing in
the morning when I know I shouldn't
because that makes me burn my children's
toast why do I want to train for a
marathon and here is one of my favorite
wise
asked by me but by an older man when he
was the one he listened to my public
reading and he said why did I tell
myself this morning now the piece of
cake I ate was good for me but we don't
but we don't live to answer all these
small lies we shouldn't any exhausted
exhausted parent of small child can
relate to that why do I have to wear
shoes why do I have to brush my teeth
why can't I sleep in the dog bed where's
the puppy and then there are the big
why's the big whys are not always
answerable in fact we may say that they
are big lies because they can be
answered one of the danger of living is
that inevitably we run into people who
think that every Y has an answer and
they demand us to answer for them and
while we can provide a satisfactory
answer they would do that for us often
with a hasty and judgment Oh answered
big lies are life and death or in the
piece but small lies when we can't find
answers well when we don't even have to
find answers but just acknowledge them
insulate and sustain us
[Music]